First You're Gonna fry the plantains and
place it on a baking sheet make sure you
cover it with cheese and put it in the
oven and broil for about two to three
minutes Shred the brisket in their own
juices so you don't want the brisket to
get too dry add a good amount of brisket
to our first layers of nachos make sure
you add a little bit of those juices
from the brisket at the barbecue sauce
tomatoes jalapenos are great because
they're going to bring a little bit of a
sweetness to it besides the little spice
take the salsa and kind of just sprinkle
on top of it as well more cheese now we
have another layer of plantains add a
little bit of a sour cream sprinkle a
little bit of cilantro and then micros
that's going to be another little spice
on top avocados are you last but not
least add them last so they don't turn
brown keeping for that beautiful green
color on top of them and we have a
little bit more of brisket juice so why
not